it has been a very trying year
but we should not let up now the first
task is
of course to achieve widespread
vaccination
so we are working with the companies to
ramp up production and address
bottlenecks in the
supply we are ensuring speedy
availability of new production plants
in europe a good example is recently
biontech
starting the new plants in austria and
in germany marburg
a brief look on the variants what we do
need
to do is support the rapid detection of
new variants
through cooperation with member states
notably
by increasing the sequencing
for that the european commission is
providing 200 million euros
to the legal framework that ecdc is
offering
to allow member states within this
legal framework to contract for
sequencing
i am glad to say that leaders confirmed
their strong support
for the hera incubator today so we can
get
down to work now on the vaccine
certificates as you know
there are still a number of open
question political questions but
at the eu level i believe we should use
them to ensure the functioning
of the single market and we offer from
the commission side
to coordinate on the standards like
we've done with
the tracing app and to create a gateway
that connects the different national
solutions with each other
so that this information is
interoperable
over time